all right people this
is the reuben report direct message i'm
still dave rubin and we are just
days out from the big election can you
believe it just
days out from the very day that will
decide the future
of humanity we're almost there guys i
voted yesterday
that's gonna be one of our stories i
didn't even have to show my id it was
really wonderful i
would have to show my id to buy a beer
even though i'm 44 years old i still get
id'd but you don't have to show your id
to vote so we're going to talk about
that
we are going to talk about measure 16
here in california where the
progressives
the wonderful lefties are putting racism
back into the system and we got to vote
on it so i voted on it i'll show you
what i
decided on whether i wanted the country
to be more racist or less racist
and we'll read the exact text and uh you
know if you don't have systemic racism
in the system which we don't hear in the
united states there are no
racist laws uh the best way to get
systemic racism so
you can use it to fuel the fire of
burning everything down that you're
trying to do
is to put it on the ballot especially
here in california because these people
are idiots
so we're going to cover that then we're
going to talk about coronavirus deaths
because
they are dropping believe it or not the
media seems to be pushing this notion
that they're they're growing again
everything's going up and up and up it's
a little hard to decipher some of the
information
because obviously as we test more we see
more
rising cases this is where trump always
gets lost in language because people say
well
he always says well if we weren't
testing we wouldn't see the numbers
going up and people are like no the
numbers would still go up
you're both kind of correct uh if we
weren't testing that means
uh numbers could be going up or down we
wouldn't know so the more you test the
more you're going to see that the
numbers
are going up in case if in fact they are
going up
but in essence there is a new study that
is confirming
the fact that deaths are dropping
despite cases rising so we'll get into
some of the numbers
i hope you brought your calculator and
then the third story for today
is that big tech hearing yesterday uh i
focused mostly
on jack dorsey yesterday and the fact
that he basically lied under oath
ted cruz and could be in a lot of
trouble for doing that you guys know all
the
all the stuff about big tech censorship
and the rest of it but then something
really
interesting happened where mark
zuckerberg who of course is the
synthetic humanoid that's in charge of
uh facebook uh he did not know
apparently that the head of
election integrity at uh
facebook used to work for you're not
gonna believe it guys
joe biden can i know it's so weird it's
just
it's just so weird so we're going to get
into all that i'm feeling good today i'm
highly caffeinated i put on a jacket for
you
and before we do anything else guys i
want to talk to you
about built bar are you guys looking for
a new protein bar that tastes like a
candy bar
i've got just the brand for you bill
bars are super tasty and come in 18
amazing flavors my personal favorite as
you know already
is the cookies and cream that i've got
right here but we've got a box filled
with all kinds
and i've been trying them and they're
good people build bars are covered in
100
chocolate include both nut and nut-free
flavors and are soft and easy to chew
with halloween just days away it's easy
to slip up which is why build bars are
the perfect alternative to candy for the
health conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber i'm not
making up guys
the six pack ain't quite there yet but
we're getting close go to builtbar.com
and use promo code ruben and you'll get
20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for
20 off your first order at billbar.com
good for built
bars built go or build boost and now
back to me
hello all right so i voted yesterday
guys
i i early voted uh david and i went to
our local
polling station we brought our ids we
brought some documentation showing where
we live
the whole thing we got in the car we
went in
and we voted uh we did not have to show
ids we did not have to show any
identification
i did not realize that i actually didn't
realize that i remember
that during the primaries where i did
vote that i didn't need anything and i
thought that was a little bizarre and i
know there's always this ongoing thing
about
voter ids but i thought surely at the
national election
someone's gonna check something right
like that you can't just walk in just
say you are whoever you
are and know someone's address and vote
as them
but that is literally what you can do
here in the banana republic of
california so i said my name
and i said my address i did not show any
evidence that i am me
or that i live in that place and then i
went up to the machine and it was
electronic and touchpad and the whole
thing and i and i did my thing
but quite literally and and i don't want
people to feel that the election is
illegitimate obviously you don't want to
but we do have to secure our elections
at some level
the idea that you don't have to show an
id so i could actually go back
i could get in my car right now and in
eight minutes be at my polling station
again
and assuming that they didn't know who i
was i could say yeah i'm bob blah blah
and i live
and then i could vote as bob and then
bob could show up and i guess bob would
be screwed i mean the idea
let's just be very very clear on this
the only people who don't want voter id
id laws are the people who are for voter
fraud okay
everyone can get an id you need an id to
buy a beer you need an id
to drive a car you need an id to get on
a plane but for some reason if we say to
people you need an id to vote
which is your most important civic duty
somehow that's construed as racist right
it's racist
or you don't want poor people to vote or
something like that everyone can get an
id virtually everyone has an id
it's offensive if you were to say a lot
of well black people don't have ids what
are you talking about
you're racist do you guys realize that
you guys are the racist you call
everybody racist but you're
the actual racist i i have plenty of
black friends they all have id's i'm
fairly certain i know who they all are
uh the whole thing is so stupid
um but so the idea that you can do this
is kind of crazy
uh but let's talk about who i voted for
and and
one of the measures that i voted on we
we can throw up the image
because it's out there already i did
vote for donald
j trump and michael r
pence those are the people that i voted
for
i've been telling you guys for probably
about four months that was the direction
i was headed in
uh right before i went off the grid for
august i did kyle kashub's podcast and
he flat out
asked me who i was going to vote for and
i hadn't said it publicly yet but
obviously i've been thinking this for
for many many months at this point uh
that that trump was the right choice do
i think trump is perfect let's do all
the asterisk
stuff first do i think trump is perfect
i don't do i wish sometimes he tweeted
less
i do is there something kind of funny
about his hair
yes etc etc but
has he basically done a good job as
president
let's put corona virus aside for one
second i i will address it
uh in just a moment and our whole second
story is about corona before cronut did
we have an
absolutely thriving economy which by the
way today we're getting some numbers
that are really really good on the on
the rebound we did
and we had all-time low black
unemployment and all-time low
latino unemployment absolutely
this piece in the middle east thing
israel signing all of these deals with
middle east countries
that's good that that's good we all used
to want middle east peace now orange man
we don't want it so much anymore
uh the changing of some of these crazy
international deals that we had like the
paris climate accords that was a
non-binding deal
that in effect we were paying for and
now we're out of and by the way
uh i've read and you guys can find the
articles yourself in many cases were
were actually exceeding
some of the numbers that were dictated
to us by the paraclimas accord
by the paris climate accords this is a
good thing getting rid of regulation
lowering taxes all of these things are
good
oh and i forgot the big two taking
critical race theory
out of the universities and out of our
federal institutions this is beyond
massive if if you hate identity politics
if you love america if you believe
people should be treated as individuals
trump trump had the the most
intense death blow to those bad set of
ideas when he said the government will
not institute these ideas
um this is huge so he got critical race
theory out
he also reversed title ix title ix was
the obama
executive action that in essence took
away due process so if a male student
it did a few things but one of them that
was used quite frequently was that if a
male student was accused of sexual
harassment
basically you could be kicked out of
college just by the accusation we
removed due process
well trump got rid of that when he
brought in betsy devos's education
secretary
there there is a series of good things
he's done
but all of those things combined i would
still say
even maybe the bigger thing is that he
has fought the media he has fought the
establishment
and and no other republican was going to
do it and
and you know yeah you might go that
mccain guy was nicer and that romney guy
was nicer and whatever it is
those guys lost trump has mapped out a
way for right-leaning people
conservatives disaffected liberals
libertarians
to fight the machine and that was
that was worthy of my vote it doesn't
mean he's perfect and i have no doubt
that i'm gonna have more hit pieces
written about me and that
the rest of the the anger and the hate
will come but as i often say i am my own
boss and the chances that i fire myself
are pretty slim i suppose it could
happen one day
um so that that is who i voted for i
voted for trump i was actually very
happy to vote for trump and i know
again i'm gonna have i'm gonna have not
only hit pieces but i know
people in my life are not gonna be happy
with me but um you know when i was off
the grid i watched this
frank sinatra documentary on netflix
it's a two-part
about two hours each documentary on
frank sinatra and i love frank sinatra
and the old crooners and the rat pack
and all that
but there's a moment where he's talking
about elections and voting and things
like that he was very politically active
as a democrat at first and then
eventually
he became friends with ronald reagan who
became the republican governor of
california and obviously ultimately
president
and he started the media started turning
on him frank sinatra was like a darling
of the media
when he was a democrat and then you're
not gonna believe it this stuff has
obviously gone on for decades when he
started becoming a little more
conservative or at least supporting a
california conservative
ronald reagan the media started going
after him and he gave this you should
watch it in the documentary
there's just this couple lines on just
how it's your duty as a man
to to do what you think is right and
vote for the people you think is right
and you have to do that
and don't let people cower you and scare
you into doing what they want so i hope
i hope if you're on the fence right now
whichever way you're going to go that
you do what your conscience tells you to
do
and not what the mob tells you to do i
think that's that's the most important
thing
that you can do so anyway so i voted for
trump and i didn't have to show my
id so tomorrow i'll vote for trump again
it's very very exciting
and uh and now i want to shift a little
bit to to measure
16 because you know when you vote uh
there's all sorts of people you can vote
for i also by the way i voted for eric
early
who is running against adam schiff that
that russia collusion maniac so i voted
for eric early who's the republican
running against him i also voted
basically no
on all of the measures because
everything increases taxes sorry state
you can't have any more
money from the people you don't deserve
any of it there might have been one or
two exceptions to that
um but basically i voted no on all of
those things
and i voted you know i tried to figure
out who were the least
lefty people though in this state it's
pretty bananas um
but you do vote on several measures and
i want to talk about measure 16
specifically so let's let's throw the
image up there and i'm going to read you
a little bit
about what measure 16 is it will allow
diversity as a factor in public
employment education
and contracting decisions legislative
constitutional amendment
just to be very clear it will allow
diversity as a factor
in public employment education and
contracting decisions
meaning they will care about your skin
color your gender
and your sexuality the stuff that we did
the 64 civil rights act to get rid of
we shouldn't care about those things
martin luther king
we're not going to care about the color
of your skin that's what he didn't want
for his kids he wanted them to care
about the
content of their character but not here
in california apparently
and i'll just read two parts of this
thing this
proposition would permit the government
permits government decision-making
policies to consider
race sex color ethnicity or national
origin
to address diversity by repealing
article 1
section 31 of the california
constitution so we are amending the
constitution to put systemic racism into
it
which was added by proposition 209 in
1996.
okay you got that people so 24 years ago
we said let's get discrimination
out now we're going to vote it back in
apparently uh proposition 209 generally
prohibits state and local governments
from
discriminating against or granting
preferential treatment to
individuals or groups on the basis of
race sex color ethnicity or national
origin
in the operation of public employment
education or contracting
that's the good one you morons that's
the one
209 we wrapped this thing up in 96
okay that's the good one prohibits state
and local governments from
discriminating against or granting
preferential treatment to
individuals on the basis of raise sex i
read it already
i circled it here i put a box
over the circle what is wrong with you
people
so we are literally right now in
california voting to put
racism voting to put discrimination
voting to put bigotry back into the
system
and and let me just try this this way if
you are one of the people
who thinks oh but we do want more
diversity well i
understand that that's a nice thought to
have
now think about it this way would you be
for discriminating against someone
based on their skin color sexuality
gender or anything else
ah gotcha didn't i because if you
elevate somebody because of those things
you have to de-boost to use their
language somebody because of those
things
so this is nonsensical it is psychotic
i'm fairly certain
it's against the constitution of the
united states and this is the type of
thing that could end up as a supreme
court decision
um so good luck with that amy coney
barrett
um but it's it's just it's just
ridiculousness i wonder if if this is
happening in any other states can you
guys let me know
uh throw some comments in there if you
see this happening anywhere besides
california
this loony loony place oh and before we
move on to the next story
i should mention that uh the president
you know this guy
trump um i was on fox and friends this
morning i was up at
4am for like a 5 15 uh fox and friends
appearance
and then i went to sleep i basically was
on at 5 15
until about 5 20 then i tried to go to
sleep for about two hours
i woke up my phone was hot you know when
you know it like your phone's going
crazy
and it's like you got like a nuclear
device in your hand and you just throw
this thing and it's gonna explode
um well trump uh tweeted this about me
we'll throw it up there
uh thank you to dave rubin author of
don't burn this book
just announce on fox and friends that he
is voting for your favorite president
me i think donald trump has done a lot
of good
when i see an american flag i see trump
support
well i just laid out there why i think
that a vote
excuse me why i think a vote for trump
is is sensible and is good and is fair
and it doesn't make you a racist or a
bigot or anything else
um but i you got this is like one of
those things where it's like the way he
writes these things it's like
voting for your favorite president me
there's no business like show business
like that that's kind of where we're at
at this point um in any event it was it
was nice to
see that i already got some people
texting me that are that are angry at me
because the president tweeted at me you
know in the old days if the president
said something nice about you people
would support you it's a little bit of a
strange thing these days
um okay let's let's talk about
coronavirus because obviously there are
there are critics of trump and people
who won't vote for trump because of
coronavirus
um so i wanted to hold this to the to
the second story that we're doing right
now
let's throw the graph up there
so npr and they're you know these are
not people that like trump
studies point to big drop in cobit 19
death rates
uh this is updated as a few days ago i'm
just going to read a little bit
two new peer-reviewed studies are
showing a sharp
drop in mortality amongst hop
hospitalized covet 19 patients
the drop is seen in all groups including
older patients and those with underlying
conditions
suggesting that physicians are getting
better at helping patients survive their
illness
mortality has dropped amongst
hospitalized patients
by 18 percentage points since the
pandemic began
the people who are getting hospitalized
now tend to be much younger tend to have
fewer other diseases and tend to be less
frail
than people who are hospitalized in the
early days of the epidemic
okay i wanted to do this story because
this is showing you
that we're rounding the corner we
flatten the curve we're rounding the
corner other
assorted statement that doesn't really
explain what's going on
these are good things right these are
good things you would report
on spiraling death tolls if if you
wanted to show the truth but if you
really want to
do it just to get trump then you're not
going to show this so my guess is cnn's
not going to be doing much
on this today right the new york times
ain't going to be doing much on this
today
um but the simple truth is the doctors
are dealing with it better we're seeing
less older people die
we also know that younger people that
get the disease they survive
as i said a few weeks ago i know a few
people that have gotten coronavirus
they were sick for a few days one of my
friends was sick for about 10 days but
most were sick for two or three days i
have a friend that got it that had no
symptoms whatsoever
um that you will get past it and you
will survive the idea
that we have decided to shut down the
entire country destroy people's
livelihoods
as i said yesterday now we know that
alcoholism is rising suicide is rising
people are not getting out they're not
exercising they're not seeing other
human beings we're spending
all our days like automated robotic
human autonomous i mean it's it's just
we we made a mistake along the way and
where are all of the people where are
the freedom-loving people saying it's
time
to move forward and and just imagine
just imagine
if biden gets in charge and and the
democrats are in charge
biden wants a federal lockdown you want
to just keep giving these people
more power over you gavin newsom cannot
tell me what i can do for thanksgiving
i'm going to do whatever the hell i want
to do you can i'm telling you directly
right now gavin newsom
i'm going to have as many people as i
want and we're gonna do whatever the
hell we want and that might include
singing which i know you don't want
people to sing you freak
um so anyway it's important to know that
the numbers are going down in terms of
mortality
people are not dying as much people are
getting better
and and just know that and then take and
of course
take whatever precautions you see as
necessary
to take care of yourself and take care
of your family but the point is it
should be on you
it should be on you not only as an
individual citizen but it should be on
you
as a business owner or as a coach of a
baseball team
or whatever it is you do let the the
people
the people should make the decisions not
these edicts from people that would love
to keep us locked down forever
all right story number three feeling
very focused today people
can you feel it very focused uh mark
zuckerberg was at the big uh
the big big tech hearing yesterday and
uh
you know to do a big tech hearing about
big tech uh
for the senate right before the election
is is kind of late so yes it's
it's a lot of theater right it's a lot
of theater because nothing
even if they they talked to everybody
yesterday and they even if they
unearthed oh my god we found out the
code that they wrote in the algorithm
that is suppressing things and that is
amplifying things and everything else
it's like well the damage has been done
as far as this election right like
there's
there's nothing that can be done in in
these now
four or five remaining days to fix the
misinformation the suppression of views
and all of those things
this is all about maybe that something
can be done in the future
but i would say the idea of the hearing
is good because getting
jack and and zuckerberg and the google
guy getting these guys
out there to talk does bring it forward
in the national conscious gets us
hopefully to think about some of the
issues and that kind of thing
but but don't be confused it's not as if
they're going to do something tomorrow
that's going to save us from big tech it
ain't it ain't happening
and as i always say big tech is not
purely evil
right it's like a fire fire can do good
stuff warm up the house fire can also
burn down the house
and and i i'm here because of the pipes
of youtube
so so i get it i get it right although
you should join us at reubenreport.com
because i do fully own that and can
communicate
directly with you and we can build great
communities for you check out locals.com
um anyway there's a there's an
incredible exchange between
john thune senator john thune and mark
zuckerberg so i'm going to read a little
bit of the exchange because this just
sort of sums up
the negligence of our media the the way
big tech treats us like children and
sort of just the
general state of everything so john
thune said
to zuckerberg the person that is in
charge of election integrity and
security at facebook
is a former joe biden staffer is there
someone closely associated with
president
trump in the same role at facebook
he went on to say how do you all respond
to the argument that there isn't
sufficient balance in terms of the
political ideology or diversity in your
companies
and how do you deal with the lack of
trust that creates
amongst conservatives to which mark
zuckerberg replied
i think having balance is valuable and
while we
and we try to do that dot dot dot i am
not aware of the example
of you say of someone in charge of this
process who worked for biden
in the past so we can follow up on that
well it is in fact true that the person
in charge
of integrity and security at facebook
that they are a former biden staffer now
of course that
shouldn't really surprise you and by the
way i don't necessarily begrudge people
moving from
say being a political staffer to having
another job or working at big tech and
people move bounce around between
industries and all of those things
but in this case and especially in this
highly polarized
world that we live in it's like if you
don't think he's bringing some of those
biases
if you don't think some of those are
kind of getting in getting into the
system for the guy that's in charge of
the election stuff at facebook
you know then then i'd like to i'd like
to sell you something because
of course it's happening right of course
it's happening so the fact that
zuckerberg basically said he wasn't
aware
kind of tells you everything and this is
often you know what what's the famous
line the famous line the buck stops with
me
right meaning that if you're in charge
of something you can't always blame
everybody else oh no no is that
low-level staffer oh no
no he's the janitor no you know
the part-timer did that at some point
the buck stops with you
and that's why being in the position
that zuckerberg is in and being in the
position that jack dorsey is in
these are not um i would say enviable
positions to be in there there are
extraordinary problems
that you can never fully solve perhaps
and that in the case of uh jack he
probably just got himself
in a lot of trouble by by lying under
oath ted cruz caught him
watch our video from yesterday if you're
not sure what i'm talking about um
so look zuckerberg's saying he's not
aware it's like all right i don't know
if you're lying or not if you're lying
then there's a problem
but if if you are in line that just
shows that you're not really in charge
of your company like a decision well who
who was in charge then like who made the
decision
if not you the ceo i do believe that
you've got to manage this entire
unimaginably huge organization
so then who was in charge was it a vp
was it someone in hr who made the
decision what was the thought process
and now do we have evidence that this
person is manipulating things
again it's all too late for this
election so so we shall see what
what happens all right guys i'm gonna
jump right now i got i got a crazy day
uh i just shot a podcast with glenn beck
that'll be up over at the blaze
soon got a few other things we're
shooting later this afternoon uh we are
doing a direct message tomorrow this is
a five day a week week for us
uh it's going to be a q a i suspect
it'll be mostly about election stuff
all with the reuben report community so
you can uh submit a question you can do
it right now at rubinreport.com or
download our ios app
or our google play app just search ruben
report in either one of the stores
uh q a tomorrow and then next week we're
announcing our election coverage
i'm going to be doing some live stuff in
studio with the daily wire guys i'm
going to be doing some stuff
via the pipes via the wires with the
blaze guys and then we're going to do
at least one live stream the night of
the election probably two
and then when the election is not
decided that night we'll be doing live
streams every day from
uh then until perpetuity until the earth
explodes which according to aoc is in
about 11
years and six months so it's going to be
it's going to be a hectic time
uh all right guys i'll see you tomorrow
and if you want to submit questions
run over to reubenreport.com have a
great day everybody
you